hey there I'm AJ from random encounters
I'm Peter sort of awesome where I guess
I'm doing an interview for film courage
when did you start your channel is about
a year ago we've been running our
channel random encounters for about a
year now we just celebrate our first
birthday yeah about 1 month ago had a
big party yeah laser tag now laser tag
sadly tubers and invited them we don't
have too many friends on YouTube yet
unfortunately we're still trying to
that's why we're here actually we're
you're making friends exactly they can
come to our second birthday we're from
Los Angeles actually we're based up in
Lancaster which is about 45 minutes
north but we're down here constantly
anyway filming or seeing her friends so
yeah we were down here 4a m squared we
had a panel so it was at this convention
center like two weeks ago right so we
have that and we shot a musical number
last week for for Sega so we've been
this is basically like two hours away
from us and front from where we live but
we've been here every week for the last
three weeks it gives me a bit friends
that we can stay with things like this
no we're well connected at this point
from going to do oh yeah
we have about 2 million channel views
but to the tune of about eight thousand
subscribers right now yes it like that
I'm told that that's after 180 right
here I hear success stories well beyond
what we're doing but we keep looking at
it any size I have no doubt that by our
next birthday we can double that
well I mean others are challenged I
think it's just that part's easy okay I
mean I'm in double the rate that we're
going oh the rate yes how you think
about exponential increase I hear that
the more subscribers you have and the
more you're being seen the quicker you
get seen even more because those people
are spreading to more people so
hypothetically we should be able to
improve her I think we're the only
people here doing this but we do
musicals out of video games will take a
video game like pokemon or Zelda and
we'll write and direct a musical number
based on it usually in costume which
includes yes the costume includes
writing the song and the the lyrics and
writing any non-singing stuff too and
then we go out in film it and we headed
it and it goes up and it looks like a
show to enough to avoid Broadway but
it's a video our music video I suppose
but only a goofy-looking music very
goofy yeah
Wow
we only have like three friends and Mike
it's a really small they still have
three friends three friends yes oh you
do know woke a no it's we're new to the
area to we only moved up there somewhat
recently when we realized we were trying
to do for YouTube based stuff we thought
we're not tethered that anywhere
specific let's save a little bit on rent
you look to Lancaster we're also I think
you're allowed to go out in the desert a
little easier to film thing
you